[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit kai soll
richter und marietta slomka guten abend
ein atomkraftwerk als kriegsbeute und
unter beschuss auch heute wieder jedem
dürfte wohl klar sein wie gefährlich das
ist ob es an der mission der
internationalen atomenergiebehörde
gelingt dort nächste woche hin zu reisen
ist nach wie vor unklar im moment laufen
dazu verhandlungen derweil die russische
armee auf den ukrainischen
schlachtfeldern weiter massive
feuerkraft einsetzt ohne dabei aber
wirklich große geländegewinne zu machen
und dort wo es den ukrainern gelingt sie
zurückzudrängen hinterlassen großen
nichts als verbrannte erde in jeder
hinsicht hannah hebestreit berichtet
seit 185 tagen kämpfen russische truppen
jetzt schon in der ukraine
diese bilder des russischen militärs
zeigen dass immer noch viel geschossen
wird aber aus der inversion ist längst
ein stellungskrieg geworden dort wo sich
russische truppen zurückziehen mussten
wie hier im ort moscheen und von epi
gedenken nachbarn der getöteten familie
von alleine die besetzer hatten im märz
ihre eltern und den bruder gefoltert
getötet und verscharrt
russland mir meine familie genommen
meine welt zerstört und
unser leben zerbrochen
kiews metropolit alexandra vinco
persönlich ist nach moting gekommen
zelebriert selbst die gedenkzeremonie am
grab von den opfern der russischen
aggression er hat eine mission will dass
möglichst viele kirchengemeinden der
russischen orthodoxie abschwören und
sich der ukrainisch orthodoxen kirche
anschließend
[Musik]
dem motto schien ist der hoch willkommen
als die russen den ort besetzten
verschwand der alte priester der neue
lässt sich von ihm heute zum schwein
eine lange wird türkische zeremonie
an deren ende bekräftigen die
dorfbewohner auch ihren über drittel
ukrainische orthodoxie
das ganze dorf war darüber beraten und
wir haben entschieden ihr nichts
russisches mehr haben zum
russlands verrückte und unmenschliche
aggression war der letzte anstoß für uns
niemand hatte mehr zweifel dass es
richtig ist zur ukrainischen kirche zu
müssen
mehr als 500 auto doppel
kirchengemeinden haben sich bereits seit
kriegsbeginn von der moskauer
kirchenführung losgesagt damit schwindet
russlands einfluss auf die gläubigen in
der ukraine
und
weißrusslands griechen hier haben
versteckt und auch ganz offen die
menschen in der ukraine beeinflusst und
auch die invasion gerecht vertrieb tätig
hatte post in den kirchen haben sie auf
erbeutete russische munitionskisten
ikonen gemalt die angreifer haben die
angestrebten invasions ziele nicht
erreicht die einheit der ukraine dagegen
geschlossen
dann schalten wir noch zu unserem
reporter in der ukraine hannah ein
anderes großes thema in diesem krieg
sind die geschehnisse am atomkraftwerk
buschehr
die ist da jetzt die lage welche
informationen hast du
hast du dir schon eine anmoderation des
beitrages gesagt da gab es am nachmittag
auch wieder gefechte ist sondern auch
treffe auf dem gelände der anlage
gegeben haben die ukrainische betreiber
gesagt verspricht von schäden an der
infrastruktur was immer das genau heißt
wissen wir nicht beide seiten
bezichtigen sich gegenseitig geschossen
und getroffen zu haben
wir haben mit einer reaktor
sicherheitsexperten hier in der ukraine
gesprochen sie sagte die gefahr einer
reaktorkatastrophe bei einem treffer der
anlage sei gar nicht so wahnsinnig hoch
viel schlimmer sei es wenn der strom für
die kühlaggregate ausfalle dann könnten
schlimmstenfalls schlimmstenfalls mit
einem drei stunden eine kernschmelze
eintreten
davon sei dann aber auch unter umständen
russisches gebiet betroffen also das ist
alles eine ganz komische gemenge lage
dort unten man erhofft sich schon dass
die inspektoren der internationalen
atomenergiebehörde
in den nächsten tagen etwas licht in das
dunkel bringen gibt es da wenn es noch
nähere informationen zu
ja es konkretisiert sich wohl dass das
tatsächlich nächste woche losgeht unter
umständen schon am montag und den
vorsitz dieser gruppe würde direktor der
behörde habe der argentiner rossi dann
sollen 13 weitere mitglieder der behörde
unterwegs seien davon aber niemand aus
den usa oder aus england es seien vor
allem aus neutralen staaten beteiligte
dabei also das sind jetzt unsere
informationen dass sie nächste woche
spannend werden danke den hängern nach
kiew
wenn geflüchtet für aus syrien solche
berichte über russlands krieg in der
ukraine sehen weckt das traumatische
erinnerungen die tödlichen bomben die
zerstörungen die folterungen all das gab
und gibt es hier auch in syrien und auch
durch russisches militär das sich an
diesem krieg ja intensiv beteiligt putin
sicherte dem assad regime die macht und
testete dabei nebenher umfänglich seine
waffensysteme unter anderem durch
großflächige sbordone der bevölkerung
ein weiterer großer akteur im syrien
krieges die türkei
präsident erdogan will vor allem
verhindern dass in nordsyrien im
grenzgebiet zur türkei dauerhaft ein
kurdisches autonomiegebiet entsteht und
so haben die menschen in nordsyrien
gleich drei feinde die türken die russen
und das assad-regime
polizei berichtet ein freitagmorgen in
alberta östlich von aleppo es ist die
zeit in der familien sich zum einkaufen
und essen sammeln als die raketen
einschlagen
wahrscheinlich raketen des regimes in
damaskus deswegen einschlag winkel und
raketen
sie treffen ein verlaufe restaurant sie
töten den brot verkäufer sie zerstören
wohnhäuser und eine schule
im krankenhaus von alba etliche kinder
sind unter den verletzten und toten
mustafa acht jahre alt hätte fast seine
beine verloren er weiß nicht dass ein
vater tot ist der seine kleine cousine
mit der er gerade spielte in stücke
gerissen wurde
das haus in dem er spielte ist jetzt
eine halbe ruine
mustafas onkel unter schock das leben in
nordsyrien ist hart genug der friseur
kann seine familie kaum ernähren jetzt
hat er keine tochter und keinen kunden
mehr
und ist sein vater obdachlos geworden
wohin sollen sie noch flüchten in ein
zelt wie millionen andere syrer hier
der westen muss uns helfen dieses
blutvergießen zu beenden
gegen unschuldige zivilisten die nichts
getan haben wir verlangen
entschädigungen ich habe alles verloren
doch der krieg geht weiter ohne dass die
welt ihn wahrnimmt allein in diesem
monat wurden mindestens 310 kinder
getötet und dutzende verletzt hier
zählten russische flugzeuge auf
vertriebenen
wenige kilometer entfernt türkischer
angriffe gegen kurden hier tötete eine
wahrscheinlich türkische drohne zwei
kinder und im nordosten des landes vier
volleyball spielen de teenager
sie treiben die eskalation russlands
präsident schutzmacht des regimes in
damaskus baut seinen einfluss in den
kurdischen gebieten aus
präsident erdogan drohnen und artillerie
drängen die kunden zurück zugleich sucht
erdogan erstmals auf putins bitten hin
den dialog mit damaskus die kriegsherren
halten die bevölkerung nord syriens im
zangengriff
wenn wir es wenn der humanitären seite
aus betrachten dann ist es eine sich
ständig verschlechternde situation wenn
dann auch noch weitere militäroffensiven
stattfinden die kein problem lösen wohl
aber sehr viel neue probleme mit sich
bringen dann ist es etwas was uns alle
hier beschäftigen sollte das dürfte
weitere flucht bewegungen auslösen
dramatisch ist jedoch dass es natürlich
eigentlich keinen ort gibt an denen
diese geflüchtet dann können sie kommen
in keinem politischen planspiel fuhr die
menschen in albert die um ihre toten
trauern jede annäherung an damaskus
fürchten sie könnte ihre lage noch
verschlimmern und für sie alle tot oder
gefängnis bedeuten
und jetzt noch das nur selber richter
weiter mit den nachrichten da schauen
wir auf die innenpolitik wegen der hohen
energiepreise will bundeskanzler scholz
den kreis der wohngeldempfänger
ausweiten außerdem kündigte er weitere
entlastungen an von denen ausdrücklich
auch rentner und studierende profitieren
sollen um menschen mit wenig einkommen
zu unterstützen wirbt spd-chef klingbeil
erneut für eine über gewinn steuer diese
könne die möglichkeiten für entlastungen
erweitern sagte er den funke zeitungen
in vier tagen endet das neuen euro
ticket doch das wollen viele nicht
hinnehmen bundesweit gegen tausende für
eine verlängerung auf die straße zum
beispiel in mainz zu dem aktionstag
hatte ein bündnis aus verschiedenen
organisationen aufgerufen es fordert ein
umschichten von bundesmitteln weg vom
auto hin zu bus und bahn da ist es
dieses wochenende auf ziemlich eng denn
viele wollen ihren neuen euro ticket
noch einmal nutzen
in sachsen werden ab sofort sämtliche
asylbewerber unterkünfte stärker bewacht
das kündigte innenminister schuster an
hintergrund ist ein brandanschlag in
leipzig dort warfen unbekannte in der
nacht brandsätze auf eine geflüchteten
unterkunft das relativ kleine feuer
konnte schnell gelöscht werden
er schäme sich das sagt
ministerpräsident rutte angesichts der
unhaltbaren zustände im niederländischen
aufnahmelager tel
hunderte migranten wurden nun in andere
unterkünfte gebracht weil das
flüchtlingszentrum überfüllt ist hatten
zeitweise bis zu 700 menschen unter
freiem himmel übernachtet gestern abend
hatte die niederländische regierung
einen plan zur entschärfung der lage
angekündigt
papst franziskus hat 20 neue kardinäle
ernannt damit erhöht sich die gesamtzahl
der würdenträger auf
226 mit der zeremonie im petersdom stieg
der anteil der kardinäle die aus asien
südamerika und afrika kommen 16 der
neuen sind jünger als 80 das heißt sie
könnten an einer papstwahl teilnehmen
eine erkenntnis immerhin kann man aus
den erfahrungen der pandemie den
aktuellen verwerfungen durch die ukraine
krieg und anderen katastrophen ziehen
bei der bewältigung von krisen sind
diktaturen demokratien keineswegs
überlegen im gegenteil sie können sie
nur länger verbergen in china kommt
jedenfalls gerade eine menge zusammen
kroner krise immobilienkrise und jetzt
auch noch energie knappheit und
stromausfälle sie hängen mit einer
rekordverdächtigen dürre zusammen unter
denen teile des landes leiden seit
beginn der wetteraufzeichnungen anfang
der 60er jahre hat es einen solch
trockenen sommer noch nicht gegeben wie
rammstein berichtet
nur aus gewohnheit hat janko ihr vor
ihre gummistiefel angezogen wo sie
normalerweise auf ihrem reisfeld im
wasser steht steht sie jetzt im
trockenen
alles hier ist total ausgetrocknet es
gibt überhaupt kein wasser seit fast 50
tagen hat es hier nicht mehr geregnet
sie kann sich nicht erinnern dass es
schon einmal so lange so trocken war
wir leben von diesen feldern wenn wir
nichts ernten haben wir nichts zu essen
die provinz shanxi im südosten chinas
ist eine der wichtigsten für den
reisanbau die folgen der seit wochen
andauernden dürre und hitzewelle zeigt
auch der pro jahr sie der größte
süßwassersee des landes ist auf ein
viertel seiner eigentlichen größe
geschrumpft
der boden ist nicht schlimm mich sondern
hart spuren zeigen dass hier mal wasser
war
die pagoden insel ist keine insel mehr
eigentlich sollte sie zu dieser
jahreszeit eher so aussehen
die satellitenbilder zeigen wie groß der
see im april war und wie klein die
fläche heute ist um sich das anzuschauen
ist trauten hierher gekommen ich mache
mir auch sorgen unser trinkwasser kommt
doch von hier
von der insel aus sieht sie das was vom
see übrig ist nur noch in der mitte ist
das wasser tief genug der mit die
schiffe zum young zufluss fahren können
zudem transportproblem kommt ein
energieproblem an vielen stellen recht
das wasser nicht zur stromgewinnung in
den wasserkraftwerken
mehr kohle soll diese lücke jetzt
schließen
auch im dorf von januar wird das wasser
knapp deshalb muss sie noch sparsamer
sein
ich trete haben nur so ein bisschen auf
wenn sie wäsche wäscht fängt sie das
wasser auf um es ein zweites mal zu
benutzen zb auf dem gemüse fällt das
auch vertrocknetes sie rührt damit
dünner an in der hoffnung dass bald
regen kommt und sie neu pflanzen kann
wenn nicht wird sie in diesem jahr gar
nichts zu ernten können
heute samstag und das heißt es gibt
lottozahlen wie immer ohne gewähr
7 16 18 32 39 46 superzahl 5 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto zdf.de
und im zdf text auf seite 55 6
das wochenend wetter bleibt wechselhaft
hier sind die aussichten für morgen da
überwiegend an der nordsee und im
südosten die wolken im südosten kommen
schauer und gewitter dazu sonst gibt es
einen meist freundlichen sonne wolken
mix bei 20 bis 27 grad die neue woche
startet dann eher wolkig im norden und
er sonnig im süden allerdings kann es
dort auch mal gewittrige schauer geben
ganze bei 19 bis 28 grad
das war es auch schon von uns weiter
geht's im aktuellen sportstudio und
nachher um 0.25 gibt es dann nochmal den
letzten blick auf diesen nachrichten tag
es morgen wieder sehen
[Musik]